a marble lock and this is my wife
Felicia Bullock and we're from Chicago
Illinois
Spira and I actually went to preschool
together my mother talked about bars my
entire life she was that you don't
remember but I will come pick you up
from preschool and you will be holding
my hand and we would go home and say I'm
going to marry Bart and we met through a
mutual friend the summer before College
and when you say his name was Bart this
is not that common of a name so I was
like I was a preschool with a Bart and
he asked me where preschool once and
with him I grew up in Chicago and
Beverly my parents didn't talk to us
about money as kids I would kind of
spoil so anything I wanted I was asked
my parents for it and they give it to me
so it's the gratification um so yeah so
growing up we didn't have like any
formal conversations about money I was
definitely afraid of like credit cards
and they throwing up I don't know I
don't know why and I just kind of
carried that through my life
so coming out of college thankfully I
was able to manage my normal expenses
that have disposable income on the side
at the time I was I'm gonna call it
irresponsible but I'd have a plan for
the disposable income so if we get this
both I just went on Google and with like
budgets and in front of my my different
budgeting software or budgeting topics
or sprays into something just just
trying to get more information and
somewhat across Dave Ramsey is program
and kind of the seven baby sets and I
decided to start doing that so you guys
went through Financial Peace University
while you were dating then yes okay my
mind was not changed at all into this
view so when we got there they asked us
to introduce ourselves everybody in the
room go around the room and say why
you're here
everyone think they're in the class
because they have X amount of debt that
they want to pay off and at some point
halfway around the room I look over and
I'm thinking he doesn't have any been so
weird for me this point we weren't
engaged weren't married or anything like
that but that was my plan he knows he
knows I didn't know why because it was
an issue at the time I wanted to get
married and he wasn't saying I'm going
to marry you no message
hey Bri okay so Felicia it sounds like
mr. Bart is he's like on this get out of
that plan
he's mr. budget bark right and you're
dating him and he goes okay we got to
talk
yes we brought a brand-new car he told
me not to buy a car so and I told him
you're crazy people on my car my pants
is insane no one can do that the college
would that's where buying was really the
car that we were buying we would have to
pay it off ready yeah I didn't know he
was marrying me so I'm I'm once again I
don't need your permission to buy a car
it was a suggestion that so all kidding
aside that had to cause some conflict I
don't know any other way to say it yeah
before we actually took a few it was
very tense that's why I suggested that
we play good together and I think that
was actually the turning point we both
are a lot of fainted if we had not
gotten on board prior to getting married
and got it on the same page I think it
would have been a very rough first year
of marriage for us we were lucky that we
were taking a class early on in our
relationship person
having perfect income you know years
after being married I think that to me
all the difference be honest so we paid
off eighty one thousand dollars over the
last four years so what kind of
definitely 81,000 so the 81,000 was a
combination of both car and student
loans in a couple of red card big
student loans then big cars big and
honestly while we were engaged that was
kind of like a slower time because we
were paying for wedding so he had pretty
much mapped it out right after the
wedding all around this timeframe will
be able to pay off the deck so two
credit cards cards so that was my day
the last thing was Ricardo and you
didn't want to send the payment you
maybe it was so scary I wanted to do it
I wasn't scared I made him do it
I was really big in shoes and sneakers
and stuff so I had you know hundreds of
pairs of sneakers when I met him he had
that wall full of shoes so yeah so I saw
all those are like almost 200 pairs of
shoes and like a month and half period
that's kind of only crazy things that
are that we did but that helped what is
it
Oh what I think I was like fifteen
sixteen thousand dollars or something
like that so
if I can summarize our lives and one
workers from sinking SCU I would say
change it's just my mind is completely
things we are completely changed as a
unit after taking it everything is just
change for the better they talked about
all the time people get divorced over
money and I could I can see why it's
much easier for us because of SVU
there's plenty of things quite about
marriage but money does not need to be
one of them being able to have somebody
who cares about the family's money and
not their own individual one it's
something that you can't even put into
words how how much that matters
[Music]
three why do we pray someone recently
asked me will we ever get into debt
again or something like that
there's no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]